هذه مقاطع فيديو نشرتها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه هذا الخميس تقول انها لدبابات من
نوع 72 تسير بسرعه فائقه ثم تطلق النيران
على مواقع قالت انها للقوات الاوكرانيه
المتواليه داخل الغابات
وهذه مقاطع اخرى لانظمه صواريخ مضاده
للطائرات وهي بمثابه درع جوي باتجاه كراسي
فيما اعلنت انها قصفت نقاط القياده ومواقع
المخابرات الاوكرانيه باسلحه جويه وبحريه
عاليه الدقه وبعيده المدى لكنها اقرت
بصدها جمات اوكرانيه على جبهات متعدده من
بينها اسقاط طائرات بدون طيار في مناطق
مختلفه بما في ذلك العاصمه موسكو
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه دمرت مسيره فوق
اراضي منطقه فوسكريسينسكي في محيط موسكو
الى جنوب شرق العاصمه المسيره كانت تتجه
نحو موسكو ولكنها لم تسجل اصابات ولا
اضرارا بحسب المعلومات الاوليه
من جانبها اعلنت هيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ان قواتها واصل
التقدمها في ميليتوفول وصدت الهجمات
الروسيه في باخموت وجبهات شرقيه اخرى
فيما قصفت اهدافا متعدده بانظمه صواريخ
مضاده للطائرات انظمه صواريخ لم تمنع
طائرات مزيره روسيه من قصف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه في الساعات الاولى من يوم
الاربعاء مخلفه دمارا في المباني ويبدو
انه رد روسي مماثل على اوكرانيا التي
ضاعفت في الاسابيع الاخيره من هجماتها على
الاراضي الروسيه بواسطه مسيرات في اطار
هجوم كيا بمضاد الذي بدا في حزيران يونيو